I want to know how that discussion of
the original akb48 got to 48. some guy
was like 20 and the guy was like more
they were like
30. yeah more
like 50. that's too much yeah
I just want to know why why 48. it's so
[__] I'm sure this is this is one
this is one thing I never understood
about idle groups that were that big you
know like up to like let's say eight is
like pushing it for me 10 is like the
maximum to how many I can like
reasonably follow along with I'm just
trying to think of like I feel K-pop
groups got it the best where it's like
they limit it to between like five and
fifteen like I think that's like a
manageable size even 15. even 50 yeah
five five five to ten is like a
manageable size yeah I don't know why I
view him I don't know why my mind is
managed distinction but I view like
K-pop bands I suppose very differently
to how I view Idols I guess they all
kind of different because I mean they
are Idols yeah they are Idols but I
guess they're the way that they Market
themselves very different right whereas
is it though do you think in a weird
sense I think K-Pop group groups almost
ah
I think they again they shouldn't be
talking out my ass somebody doesn't
consume either of them yeah in my head I
feel like whereas the idols focus on
I suppose catering to the customer and
interacting with the customer uh
directly K-pop groups tend to focus more
on releasing music and having kind of I
don't know in my head it's just I guess
I see it as like his idols most Idols
it's all about the fan meetups it's all
about the handshake right you know
whereas it feels that the K-pop groups
are more like yeah I'll be a fan but
it's mainly you consume it and interact
with it through all of the the media I
mean I disagree because like I could be
wrong yeah yeah this is the perspective
of a man who's talking out of his ass he
doesn't consume either I mean I'm not
super knowledgeable or either but I know
for a fact that like in Japan at least
you know like when when we think of like
Japanese Idols right like AKB 48 shoes
are the first one like just large groups
of like Japanese girls all dressed the
same you know interacting with fans like
you know if it's like the underground
idle scene and stuff like that but like
Japan also has a massive male Idol
culture as well like there are so many
[__] super groups of like just just
dudes yeah who are doing basically like
you know boy band [__] like you know
Backstreet Boys type stuff right and
it's like and a lot of that Underground
scene is yeah from the most part it's
majority filled with like all female
groups but there's also some like highly
highly dedicated like male groups as
well that do the same thing I think it's
just that there's because that whole
like underground scene of like the the
all goal groups has just been so well
documented compared to the male
counterpart maybe that's it that I think
a lot of people just aren't aware that
no there's male equivalence there's so
many documentaries about the idol
industry exactly and they're all based
around like the female groups right yeah
yeah I remember there's one that
released where it was like it was they
were they were interviewing people who
are fans of underground Idol groups and
there was one where it was like
I guess the mom was getting her like 12
year old daughter to be an idol oh I saw
that yeah and there was like a bunch of
40 year old dudes who were like paying
to have zoom calls with her yeah
it was [__] weird yeah it was like it
was just so bizarre and it was like she
would do live streams on some I don't
know some weird website it wasn't like
any of the mainstream ones and she would
get like a thousand viewers and she was
like 13. yeah I was like this is weird I
actually I actually do remember there
there is an app in Japan or website
that's specifically for I think it's
called ichinana or something yeah it was
like one of those where you can like and
you just like you watch them and you
have to like keep paying yeah yeah it's
basically like cam going except they're
not like doing sexually just like
talking basically yeah but like you can
tip to like have conversations with them
live right yeah and it's very I mean
it's one it's parasocial as [__] but
yeah it's also just like a little creepy
I mean I mean I'm the one to judge
people who want to yeah you want to
stream and make money because that's
what I [__] in my opinion it's a bit
creepy yeah yeah I think I think it's
like you know it'd be hypocrite
hypocritical of me to be like man look
at these people going online and they're
asking for money from people yeah
because you know it's actually what I
[__] do uh although thank you
thank you thank you
but I I feel like I feel like uh the
creepiness uh what it could because I
feel like when you see that 12 year old
[__] dude in the mum's encouraging me
yeah I mean we've seen that on like
YouTube as well you know some some
parents yeah
are definitely yeah like Shilling their
kids but I I guess it's because you you
in this documentary the one that was on
YouTube and I can't remember who did it
it's one of the journalists it was like
they would go and interview the dudes
who were consuming it which were like 50
year old man yeah and then that's where
you're like you know because if it's a
if it's a kid kid you like Ryan's toy
reviews where other kids are watching
yeah they're like okay that's I mean
there's still gonna be some kind of
questionable thing what's going on here
with the parents how they involved is is
it you know is it is it being run the
like in a way that is fair to the kid
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah is the
money going to the kid or not all those
questions need to be answered obviously
but it's it's like it's like it's like
fine yeah I mean obviously you would
want kids to be within kids content
because it helps you know that's dead
yeah yeah they want to be represented uh
they don't give a [__] they just want to
see other kids uh living cool lives
because that's swag but the fact that if
like 50 year old men were consuming it
and you would like you'd see this dude
on like a zoom call with like this girl
she's like 12 and you're like why yeah
like all the surface it is the most like
morally questionable thing that you
could ever see it's [__] weird even
though he may be he may go into it just
like completely [__] innocent right
like on on all you know all
circumstances right you were there
enough but still like when you just look
at it at the surface your first instinct
is what's going on there's absolutely no
need for a a 50 year old man to be
interacting with a kid in any way that
is not like a professional like a doctor
or something you know what I mean like
exactly like if you were just hanging
out with kids and you're paying to hang
out with kids
you would be on a watch list on any
other country
yeah I I mean I just find like I've
always found the psychology of the idol
industry fascinating you know yeah
especially with while watching these
documentaries because a lot of the times
you you know a lot of times you come and
you're like oh anyone you know if if
you're a
um if you're a businessman watching this
kind of stuff then obviously there's
something nefarious going on and I would
say from most of the documentaries I've
seen a lot of these people it's more of
just like they are just lonely and it's
kind of like they have like a sad story
you know with like the with the adult
Idol yeah with the adults I was like
okay yeah yeah with the adult I'm sorry
I was gonna say I was like all right if
you're lonely don't talk to a [__]
12-year-old
let the 12 year olds yeah go to the
other 12 year olds come on yeah yeah
um it's it's like it's like it to me I
find it like really interesting to see
what kind of psychology goes into how
someone really really gets you know
honestly kind of like addicted to uh
total loneliness yeah and I think
there's a lot of um conversation online
about like male loneliness but the
problem is a lot of the time he gets
hijacked by like in cells and very
lightwing conversations yeah so a lot of
the times it's kind are not it's kind of
hard to talk about but you know I do I
do think a lot of dudes out there are
very lonely yeah guys aren't good at
expressing their emotions or talking
about it so it's very hard for them to
kind of open up and kind of learn about
themselves more and know how to express
yourself so I think a lot of guys turn
to things like at least in Japan where
it's even compounded even more I think
yeah yeah you know the moment you leave
High School you don't really get pushed
to socialize much is that just
compounding like lifelong loneliness
that when you get to this age you're
like I have disposable income like a
cute girl can talk to me who's very
talented and yeah I can feel like we're
friends and yeah of course like this is
gonna happen especially when people are
marketing and telling you hey this isn't
weird look at all the other dudes who
are doing this you know what I mean so
it's kind of like this whole thing
that's compounding just from Japanese
society and I feel like it's happening
slowly in the like kind of Western world
but but more with other services do you
think maybe that aspect is the reason
why I like uh say like southeast Asia
light the whole [__] existence of bnk
48 and jkt 48 like do you think maybe
that maybe do you think maybe it's like
an Asian thing
I think yes uh I think definitely in
terms about in terms of just opening up
and talking about your feelings
especially in Thailand uh uh when I was
growing up mental health issues just
weren't really a thing you know it's one
in the UK until I was like 10. exactly
and even now it's still I would argue
that it's still uh especially in our
parents generation you know people in
the west may have been more aware and
may have heard about it more but it
feels like at least in you know Thai
culture and Asian culture it's not
really talked about like at all and you
know there are some things that you come
across in let's say Asian family
gatherings that uh that are just kind of
like normalized uh it's kind of like
normalized in Asian culture you go to a
family gathering and whatever whatever
weight you are you better be prepared
for your in-laws and your found me to
talk about your weight whether you're
too thin or you're too fat and you are
never the perfect to wait you are either
two Goldilocks does not exist exactly
exactly it doesn't matter too little too
much it doesn't matter if you're [__]
ripped as [__] you've been going to the
gym every day you've they're like yo
have you been carb loading I feel like
you've been carb loading a little too
much recently they will find any way to
not compliment you yeah yeah and uh the
thing is the the only way to solve that
issue is to eat more I don't know what
it is about and even if uh they say that
you overweight as [__] they'll say
you're overweight in the same sentence
where they sell tell you to eat like 10
dishes that they've took for you I don't
know why the psychology I don't I don't
know yeah um because I just I just don't
see that whole idle thing existing
outside of Asian countries like could
you imagine a [__] lnd 48 in London
or like a crd48 in Cardiff like it's
just it's just never gonna happen
although it would be kind of Epic I
think I think it's like that doesn't I
don't know why I think I just doesn't
jump well with the with the Western
mindset of like that's how they kind of
get rid of that loneliness I don't think
that's how they do it but then we have
stuff like only fans and stuff yeah a
lot of guys turn to yeah
my stream is just in general I think
yeah yeah but I think I think even then
like the way that the Japanese youtubing
set up to Western youtubing is very very
different I I think I think so I think
so yeah I think at least the way the
audience approach it yeah I think the
big difference between east and west and
in this kind of sense is that
um I I feel like idols and let's say
um you know only fan streamers and all
that kind of stuff we're both kind
they're both kind of sell a similar
product right uh it's it's like the kind
of like parasocial kind of thing where
you feel like you have a connection with
that person or with that streamer yeah
uh I just feel like here with Idols it's
just a bit more in your face
um what I feel like the big difference
is that
um at least in the west people don't
want to feel like they're being sold
something yeah they don't feel like a
fan they want to feel like a friend yeah
yeah yeah so I think when they're when
they're sold a Fan Experience yeah at
least with some people I don't think it
resonates as widely as yeah there needs
to be that natural feeling of like
self-discovery yeah yeah yeah it's just
like I wasn't sold this I made the
conscious choice to be like oh okay I I
discovered them for myself and you
slowly spiraled down into that rabbit
hole whereas with Idols it's like front
and center here are the girls they can
be your friends okay if you just paid
the money they will be your friends they
will shake your hands all right and then
Japanese people like it's that easy
okay it's like you know you can and if
you keep buying their albums maybe
they'll go on a lunch date yeah yeah
something like that you know what I mean
it's like yeah sure it is you know it's
it's a lot of the times and same thing
like girls bars right like dudes will go
to the same bar in the hopes that they
might they've paid enough money at one
point to hopefully get a date yeah yeah
yeah I also almost feel like at least in
the west the whole idea of like boy
bands and like Idol groups and stuff
like that is kind of like a past thing
like because like I don't know I feel
like J uh K-pop has really that's that's
kind of like modernized yeah I feel I
feel like Western boy bands and girl
bands have kind of you know I mean the
last one I could think of was like the
Backstreet Boys are like in sync and
that was like [__] 20 plus years ago
right so it's like since then we haven't
the West hasn't really adopted that
style at least in like the music scene
it's just because well it just goes
cable yeah I I just realized because
K-pop is just so [__] dominant yeah
no one can do it as well as that I also
think that you know you have to look at
the landscape of uh
you know agencies and contracts like in
Korea you know it's still a lot and you
know Asia in general yeah the contract
uh you know normally very heavily
favored in the producer or the person
making the group
you know whereas over the years you know
especially in places like California and
stuff like that like contracts have
become you know very very uh or
documented that it should be a lot of
abuse right so yeah now nowadays you
kind of can't make these contracts
they're all very one-sided and you can't
force the talent to do a bunch of stuff
they didn't agree to so yeah there's
like a realistic like do do we do you
really think that half of these Idol
groups or bands will perform as much if
they didn't have a producer who had a
lot of the power kind of pushing them to
do more right like realistically there'd
probably be less because did you hear
about like the Backstreet Boys contract
that they were on it's pretty uh you
know you know like Backstreet Boys right
like this is one of the most [__]
popular Western boy bands of all time do
you know how much money they walked away
with when they disbanded I don't know
how much 100 okay what yeah well yeah
like that's crazy it's so [__] they sold
that many songs the like most well-known
boy band walked away with 100K yeah
that's like that should never happen
yeah yeah like and I imagine there's
something that I you know I'm just
speculating that I imagine the deals you
know
um are always
very very heavily leaning towards way
favorite for the talent yeah it's like
for the agency yeah like you know like
in Japan like mcm's or like agencies for
YouTubers you know even though it's like
a modern thing like they're still like
very heavily skewed towards whoever's
running yeah so not not the YouTuber
yeah like I think the pretty common ones
like like for one of the YouTube uh
networks or something here was like 20
for the talent it's like 20 or 30 for
the talent yeah which is like egregious
yeah you know to give more prefer uh to
explanations what it is normally in the
west it's like tops 10 nowadays yeah it
used to be 20 you'd hear a lot but 10 is
they're kind of a stand for the agency
yeah 10 for the agency uh and yeah 90
for the talent because you're the one
making yeah exactly you're the one who
does everything so yeah you know that
makes more sense
um yeah I mean I feel like a big change
is that back then agencies just had a
lot more power uh for sure because the
internet didn't exist and now you you
because you know back when back in the
day there was no way to if you wanted to
be like independent to get your name out
there because you'd have to rely on
these big agencies that had all the
marketing power they were like we can
get you into stores and get you in
people's Radars where now you can have a
song go viral uh anything like a video
go viral and there that's boom that's
your name out you're now independent you
know
um so I feel like you know it's more
power to the artist Because the Internet
you know we complain a lot about the
internet for a lot of things but this is
one of the good thing that's come out of
it you know yeah